das ist der absolute hoch
temperaturrekord supraleitung quasi bei
temperaturen einer tiefkühltruhe strom
fließt dabei widerstandslos bei minus 23
grad celsius das ist jetzt einem
forschungsteam am max-planck-institut
für chemie in mainz gelungen ein
weltrekord und es soll noch weiter nach
oben gehen supraleitung bei
raumtemperatur würde unsere welt
verändern elektromotoren generatoren
stromleitungen alles würde kleiner und
effektiver werden klicks um
science-fiction hier gibt es täglich
faszinierendes science videos abonniert
den kanal nur dann verpasst er nichts
herzlich willkommen eigentlich wissen
wir gar nicht was da passiert wieso
funktioniert supraleitung bei so und
temperaturen 250 grad über dem absoluten
nullpunkt entdeckt wurde die
supraleitung 1911 heike kämmerling ohne
fand heraus dass quecksilber ganz
plötzlich unter 4,2 kelvin also 4,2 grad
über dem absoluten nullpunkt keinen
widerstand mehr hat wenn strom durch das
metall schließt eine der ersten
entdeckung wie sich quanteneffekte in
der realität manifestieren wie sie
wirklichkeit werden
bei der supraleitung ermöglicht das
metallgitter eine ganz besondere art und
weise wie sich die elektronen durch das
metallgitter bewegen die atome im gitter
können keinen einfluss mehr auf die
elektronen nehmen die elektronen bilden
paare und ihre wellenfunktion in der
quantenphysik winter teilchen wellen und
gleichzeitig auch teilchen kann durch
die atome im gitter nicht mehr
beeinflusst werden das gitter und die
durchfließenden elektronen bilden quasi
eine art symbiose die den widerstands
losen stromfluss ermöglicht was hat 86
entdeckten der deutsche physiker
johannes georg bednorz und der schweizer
physiker karl alex müller am ibm
forschungszentrum bei zürich die
hochtemperatur supraleitung 19 87
erhielten sie dafür den nobelpreis für
physik so schnell wurde bis heute noch
nie ein physik nobelpreis nach einer
entdeckung vergeben sie erzeugten mit
barium lanthan kubrat einer keramik
supraleitung bei 35 grad über dem
absoluten nullpunkt eine sensation
damals und die eröffnung eines wahren
wettlaufs um die höchste temperatur bei
der supraleitung möglich ist und dabei
wurde jetzt in mainz ein wirklicher
meilenstein erreicht bisher ging es ja
eher um
temperaturen über dem absoluten
nullpunkt das team um michael metz in
mainz nähert sich jetzt aber so langsam
richtig hohen temperaturen zumindest für
super leitung nämlich null grad celsius
also der temperatur bei der wasser zu
eis wird physikalisch ist das so richtig
war eigentlich schon vor einigen jahren
entdeckten sie dass schwefelwasserstoff
schon bei minus 70 grad celsius
supraleitend werden kann allerdings
unter einem druck von 2,5 millionen bar
also 2,5 millionen mal höher als hier
auf der erdoberfläche normalerweise
dabei wird so ziemlich alles was wir
kennen zerquetscht aus diesem rekord
schloss das forschungsteam das
wasserstoff der schlüssel zum erfolg
sein könnte denn solche metall
wasserstoff regierung bilden unter hohem
druck ein metallgitter und richtig beim
aktuellen rekord wurde lanthan hydrid
verwendet ein molekül aus einem land
anatom eine metall und in diesem
speziellen betrieb mit zehn wasserstoff
atomen drum herum und dieses mal wurde
weniger druck und trotzdem eine höhere
temperatur erreicht dafür befüllte das
forschungsteam eine diamant stempel
zelle mit stabilem laterne tritt es
besteht aus einem land anatom und drei
wasserstoffatom dazu presste das
forschungsteam mit zwei diamant spitzen
in der presse das land antritt und das
wasserstoffgas mit handelsüblichen im
bus schrauben immer stärker zusammen bis
sich bei einem druck von dann nur 1,7
megawatt das land anhydrit mit zehn
wasserstoffatom bildete lhc ein ganz
besonderes atom bitter und in diesem so
hergestellten metallgitter fand die
supraleitung dann bei minus 23 grad
celsius statt 250 gewinn also 250 grad
über dem absoluten nullpunkt das ist
quasi supraleitung schon fast unter in
einer ganz normalen kühltruhe
herrschenden temperaturen alles was dazu
nötig ist sind eine diamant presse und
minus 23 grad celsius so könnte quasi
jeder zu hause
supraleitung erzeugen kein flüssiges
helium und auch kein flüssiger
stickstoff wären nötig um das material
zu kühlen wenn es jetzt möglich wäre das
metallgitter auch ohne diesen
wahnsinnigen druck zu erreichen wäre das
eine absolute sensation und michael s
nicht locker als nächstes haben er und
sein team die triumphe dritte psion h10
auf dem kicker ein solches beta könnte
vielleicht schon bei temperaturen rund
um null grad celsius supraleitend werden
dann werden wir wirklich auf dem weg in
ein neues zeitalter elektromotoren
generatoren stromleitungen
magnetschwebebahnen zum beispiel und so
weiter und so fort könnten kleiner
leichter effizienter werden eine
wirklich rosige zukunft könnte uns
bevorstehen herausforderungen
supraleitung widerstandslos bei
raumtemperatur hier draufklicken da
erzählt michaela metz selbst von seinen
versuchen also draufklicken abschauen
und natürlich abonnieren bis dann bleib
dran